et nous sommes allés je respire
chercheur associé à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france expliquez nous en quoi le
retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan fragilise le pays et de
quelle façon aussi la communauté
internationale peut-elle doit-elle se
mobiliser selon vous alors la
fragilisation est toute relative
bon il ya 5000 soldats américains à peu
près ainsi 2500 vont progressivement
voyez vous on est dans des chiffres par
rapport aux deux cent mille hommes de
l'armée et de la police afghanes donc il
s'agit plutôt d'un geste politique il
s'agit plutôt d'un de commentaires si
vous voulez de communication plutôt que
de commentaires sur la réalité même du
terrain à salah est un atout
effectivement diplomatique pour les
talibans de voir la présence américaine
diminué mais elle ne change pas
fondamentalement la situation politique
sur le terrain est alors justement face
à cette situation politique comment la
communauté internationale doit elle
réagir et écouter voilà il ya déjà
plusieurs réunions qui ont eu lieu de
ces réunions quadrillé naldo qui prévoit
quatre ans d'investissement et
d'implication de la communauté
internationale vers trois objectifs la
la le premier objectif c'est de prouver
pilier c'est de continuer à asseoir tout
le processus de paix le deuxième pilier
c'est les droits de l'homme dans le sens
très large du terme à savoir donc les
éléments de la justice a en afghanistan
et surtout donc vis-à-vis des femmes non
il ya vingt ans de vie où la femme a pu
les jeunes filles ont pu s'exprimer
donc il ya 65 % des des jeunes filles
qui sont scolarisés à staff et politique
nouveau et troisièmement troisième
pilier est bien le développement
économique
ce sont ces trois points aussi qui
explique que les négociations de paix
entre le gouvernement afghan et les
négociateurs talibans ne sont toujours
pas actée alors c'est très difficile
parce que voyez vous
quand les taliban étaient au pouvoir
donc il y à il ya 20 ans il était à même
de prendre toutes les décisions c'est
eux qui dictaient la loi et elle faisait
appliquer la charia
maintenant ils sont confrontés à une
situation complètement nouvelle pour eux
c'est de participer à un gouvernement
avec à un gouvernement en place qui n'a
pas forcément les mêmes options que or
c'est toujours difficile pour un un
mouvement radical de se trouver dans une
position de participation alors qu'il a
été historiquement dans une position de
domination
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous
aujourd'hui de cette conférence des
donateurs qui commence donc aujourd'hui
à partir de janvier à genève qu'est-ce
qui peut en sortir
première manche proches que c'est à 1-1
situations importantes pour
l'afghanistan pour le pouvoir et aussi
pour la population a que le pouvoir et
la population puisse se rendre compte
que 70 pays dans le monde participe à
une réflexion par participe à un
programme d'actions pour leur pays
donc bien sûr il appartiendra aux
afghans de se prendre totalement en main
mais il y est important la situation où
le pays se trouve de savoir que la
grande majorité de la communauté
internationale celle qui dispose de
moyens financiers importants et bien les
accompagne dans leur situation politique
juridique et économique
merci beaucoup je l'espère chercheur
associé à la chaire mots